there she is I can't even tell this is
great
focus on me no hi my name is Grace help
me can do that something that you know
your life is different now
I made a cooking video recently I tried
to follow chrissy teigen recipe for
actual drunken noodles and it turned out
amazingly I don't mean to toot my own
horn but I gotta get a horn so I can
toot it I wanted to do another cooking
video today where I follow a recipe of a
very influential chef and so my
immediate thought was miss Belle miss
Taco Bell I'm going to try to recreate a
Taco Bell menu item for you right now
right here there's the deal Brooke so
you might know from such videos and
moments as what did you just say I only
wear cool clothes I've never been in the
t.j.maxx unsubscribed man this is the
definition of exploitation no this is
you blocking all them haters out there
smooth that out I get to do your makeup
with this makeup on next yeah what's
gonna be the worst possible outcome my
friends will say movies I've never taken
a drink with lipstick on yes wow what a
guy Brooks loves Taco Bell's so so much
that I texted him earlier and I said
just completely out of the blue what's
your favorite thing from Taco Bell and
then he responded immediately no
questions asked chicken quesadilla all
day and then there was no follow-up
questions that whatsoever however it he
just called me and said he's on his way
over he just went for a run should he
eat before he comes here because he
knows I'm doing something
obviously and I said no so today we're
going to try to recreate a Taco Bell
chicken quesadilla
I found the copycat Taco Bell chicken
quesadilla recipe on kitc me.com I'll
leave it in the description box below if
this doesn't turn out well it's not
because of me it's because of them
that's always fun according to them here
are the ingredients that you need
through this entire thing 1/4 cup
mayonnaise 2 tablespoons pickled sliced
jalapeno pepper minced or to taste I did
not read that correctly when I went
shopping so I just bought jalapeno
peppers and then put it in just pickle
juice
3/4 tablespoon of white sugar actually
okay so I already don't have white sugar
but I have Splenda and that's it's just
what I have brown cumin paprika cayenne
pepper to taste garlic powder salt or
flour tortillas cheddar cheese shredded
some Monterey Jack cheese shredded
eventually two slices of American cheese
which I do not have but I also bought
this pepper jack cheese so we're gonna
just use what we got and four cups of
chicken breast tenders cooked and thinly
sliced to make the sauce in a small bowl
stir together mayonnaise let's get a
small bowl I don't want a size shame you
but your smile 1/4 cup of mayonnaise let
me add two teaspoons of pickled sliced
jalapeno peppers here is our perfectly
pickled jalapenos these have been in the
refrigerator for maybe like 15 minutes
mince these 4000m 2 teaspoons of the
jalapeno pickle juice why not for fun
then we need 3 teaspoons of white sugar
squeeze one thing of Splenda even that
physic weight that's too much okay half
a teaspoon of paprika there we go eighth
of a teaspoon of cayenne pepper what why
I measure it we did it an eighth of a
teaspoon of garlic powder Psychopaths
that seems fun and a dash of salt so we
mix all this until it's smooth what a
fun not abrasive sound Oh cook my
chicken it doesn't it just says that
incorporated ingredient is cooked
chickens we can do that now
I'm sorry vegans we're doing that now
and also Brooks just showed up so you
can't see it you know what it is but you
can't see
watch oh okay well I didn't know what
the end of that sentence well enjoy your
Mountain Man it's something I never
thought I'd say to a boyfriend
else you can make noise I'm just
fast-forwarding through this part okay I
have cooked the chicken which is
something they do not explain to you how
to do but I cooked it until by my
standards it's done I also put some taco
seasoning on it because I do not trust
the flavors that we have tried to make
and at the same time I also shredded
some Monterey Jack cheese now it's time
to put our quesadilla together and
here's how this works
according to catch me calm you have to
preheat a skillet over medium heat put a
tortilla down and then you put on a
fourth cup of cheddar cheese fourth cup
of Monterey Jack cheese two slices of
American cheese if you don't have you
put 1/4 cup of chicken and then you
spread about one tablespoon of our sauce
on the tortilla and you put it together
and you let it cook so let's do that and
see what happens
you
[Music]
I care about you this is how much well
can't use this footage anymore oh I
thought you're wearing just underwear Oh
your shirt blends into your pants so
much that it looks like you're wearing
does underwear okay what would you like
to taste a fake Taco Bell chicken
quesadilla yes I made a lot of it yeah
Brooks Wheelan you may remember him from
such clips as earlier question so this
is your favorite thing to talk about it
looks really good I was gonna say you
can't judge that this looks gross
because it's tacos well really good this
is Chipotle hot chili Lula and just sour
cream I don't know how you eat yours do
I serve for you okay what Shh I do enjoy
with me I want you to try it for I think
you know also by the way but a tree
monka right yeah God does it taste at
all like talk about no because I can
tell there's real meat in this one oh
okay chicken tasted great there's well
I'm glad you like it four out of four
tacos
you did I did I'm gonna watch Andrew
Jackson destroy America also I framed
this perfectly for your reaction thanks
for watching guys so kind of subscribe
to the YouTube channel leave a comment
down below of recipes I should make in
the future
cuz this in really fun and don't forget
to hit that Bell notification so you get
notified when I upload videos because
they are consistently and can
oh I don't know oh man Deus you just
make me feel bad you're like a condiment
that's always depressed like ketchup
feels like it's the most rounded
mustards going through a rough time but
mayonnaise is like always depressed